a protected climbing route you should be
well secured and have a head for heights
mountain guide seth verneger shows how
it's done
my home is in the bachelor's garden
i'm a via padata guide and i'm going to
show you my favorite places and why it's
worth coming to visit the region around
bachelor's cotton
starting at the base station in chennai
on kernigsai lake the yenner bond takes
you
1185 meters up into the middle of the
bastis garden alps
now we've arrived at the midway station
and we'll take a little hike to my first
recommendation grandkop lookout point
it's a family-friendly hike
let's go off
from the midway station a
well-maintained trail leads up front
coupe mountain
usually there are only a few hikers here
and the mountain guide enjoys its
serenity
after 25 minutes sepp has reached his
destination
one of my favorite lookout points just
look at that panorama
what more can i say
we're a little unlucky with the weather
today the mountains are in the clouds
but unfortunately we have no influence
over that
there's a hearty lunch at the forte
brunch restaurant and a friendly
greeting
card
go on to almbach gorge sapp's second
recommendation
the three kilometer long ravine with its
waterfalls is one of the most beautiful
in the bavarian alps
29 bridges take you through it always
along the almbach river
if you want to go all the way through
the gorge plan a good three hours
it's magnificent
and always fascinating to see how the
water has shaped the rocks over the
centuries
his last recommendation is in
berchtesgaden the healing salt caves in
the salt mine
you take a train 800 meters into the
mine a huge salt deposit
the high humidity and low temperatures
of about 12 degrees celsius have a
soothing and therapeutic effect on the
lungs and air passages
many visitors including sepp find it
relaxing
on some days there's the sound of
tibetan singing bowls
after a day as full as this one was the
healing caves are just the right way to
get somebody like me to calm down and
relax
and it's here in the salt caves that sep
bernager collects his strength for
leading his hiking and climbing tours
you